joining us now is a long time critic of
this nuclear deal
center armed services committee member
and former u.s army captain senator tom
cotton from the great state of arkansas
senator what is going on with this
renewed attempt to revive this old
iranian nuclear deal
well trey you tied the
dots together there pretty well
the failed iran nuclear deal is closely
related to russia's war on ukraine as
you said for the last year
joe biden has been essentially relying
on vladimir putin to be his lawyer at
these negotiations trying to deliver
through vladimir putin a new nuclear
agreement with iran which would be much
worse than even the terrible deal barack
obama got in 2015. it would allow iran
to be a thresh threshold nuclear state
while giving them hundreds of billions
of dollars to continue their reign of
terror throughout the middle east such
as for instance shooting ballistic
missiles at erbil one of the largest
cities in northern iraq in addition to
what they also do like shooting missiles
through their proxies at major cities in
the united arab emirates or bases where
americans have soldiers or even trying
to assassinate former trump
administration officials on the streets
of the united states perhaps joe biden
should stop negotiating with the world's
worst state sponsor of terrorism and
start holding it accountable
what i can't get my head around senator
is even if they struck a deal with iran
and god knows they are trying to do so
but even if they did how would you ever
rely on them to uphold their end of the
bargain i mean how would you check it
and why would you trust iran
well that was the failure in 2015 with
barack obama's deal
it put iran on the path to being a
nuclear power it didn't even
pose many obligations on them but trey
this deal would be even worse i think
joe biden feels that he can trust iran
to keep it into the bargain because it
doesn't really even have any
responsibilities under what we've been
hearing not only would they be allowed
to become a threshold nuclear state but
president biden's even talking about
lifting sanctions against things like
the kudz force and the revolutionary
guard corps the shock troops of the
iranian regime
that are totally unrelated to their
nuclear program they face sanctions
because of their support for terrorism
their human rights abuses so i guess joe
biden's plan is that the ayatollahs will
uphold their commitments when their
commitments are essentially zero
all right senator you served in uniform
and thank you for your service there's
reporting that the pentagon wanted to
train ukrainian fighters late last year
and the state department said no
have you have are you familiar with that
reporting and why in the world would the
state department counter the pentagon
when putin is massing at the border
well i have no reason to doubt that
trade and it would be consistent with
what president biden did over the last
year again he always conciliated and
appeased vladimir putin from the very
beginning some of that was related to
the nuclear deal with iran some of it
was just president biden's natural
dovish dovishness towards russia going
back 50 years as you heard robert
o'brien earlier say we gave them an
extension of a nuclear arms control
treaty with no strings attached
whatsoever we let them continue building
that gas pipeline north stream two
underneath the baltic sea we rewarded
the last build-up on ukraine's border
with a fancy summit in europe and at the
same time we're denying ukraine what it
needed to prepare to defend itself from
this evasion like anti-aircraft missiles
which president thought would be too
provocative or apparently providing more
american trainers in december to help
train the ukrainian army on those
missiles and on other tactics again the
logic
behind those decisions is president
biden thought it would provoke
russia to invade ukraine how foolish
does it look in retrospect
yes senator that's what i'm struggling
with i mean they are bombing children's
hospitals and maternity wards and we are
worried about escalating their
hostilities i mean i i don't know what
else you can do beyond bombing maternity
wards and children's hospitals but as i
said thank you for your service to our
country my best to anna and look forward
to having you back on
thank you trey hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else